should the nba move the three-point line
back and add a four-point line
absolutely not
hi i'm dwyane wade and today i'm
answering your twitter questions this is
basketball support
the first question comes from at
trustavoid are three pointers messing
with the game of basketball would you
enjoy watching the nba if 80 of shots
were just three-pointers how many is too
many if you're making them it's never
too many if you're missing all of them
that's too many i wouldn't enjoy playing
the game with 80 of the shots being
threes but i can understand the nature
of the game today i know that three
points is more than two points and so if
his team is shooting 63s and one team is
shooting 30.
who's going to win that game coming from
a different era you want to see the game
played just the way that you played it
but you got to try to figure out a way
to appreciate the game the way it's
played in today's arrow at ta underscore
green 30 what's worse getting blown out
by 20 or losing by one because of a
buzzer beater
losing by one because of a buzzer beater
if you get beat by 20 i mean you've
known for a long time that the game was
over you get beat at the buzzer
it's immediate you don't know how to
process it so playing toronto raptors in
the playoffs in 2016 and cal lowry hit
this
like past half court three-pointer the
center game in overtime that hurt i
think if you if anybody can see the clip
you'll see my body just kind of like
fall down and fade it hurt so bad at
shooting like a god
what is the hardest shot in basketball
the open shot
sounds like it would be the easiest for
me the open shot i personally like a
contest
because a contest allows me to be able
to understand how much arc i need to put
on a shot makes me focus a little bit
more open shot it makes me think too
much so i'll take a contest
so the question is from ed miles polytic
and he asked what rule changes or
enhancements would you like to see added
or altered in the nba you know what i i
actually and i personally think the nba
does an amazing job of understanding um
that they need to adjust to the style of
play of players
that they need to always make sure they
they're adding to the game of basketball
so i came in the nba when people were
hand checking when people can put their
hands on and they can guide you over
screens and where you can go and then i
was in an era where they took your hands
off and you had to guard a guy like this
how do you guard a guy that's super fast
and super strong and you know all that
that's getting the ball screen you can't
touch him so the nba understands what
the fans need the fans at that time
wanted more scoring they wanted more
excitement and so they changed the rules
to alter that so i'm open to you know
the the evolution and the growth that
the nba always think of so i think it's
great x fast model defense debate
no middle or no baseline
great question
i've always been taught
no middle because once
the offensive player gets to the middle
everything on the court opens up and so
now you have to pull help
off of the shooters off of the scores
because the ball has penetrated the
middle of the gap right and so once the
penetrates the middle now everything
opens if you go baseline the baseliners
becomes a defender and so now all you
need is you as a defender and then just
the baseline and so i think no middle
this next question is from at
meech underscore bold you think the
triangle offense as a primary motion
offense can work in today's nba i do
i actually do to me it's not about the
offense it's about the mindset of the
players in the offense it's an offense
that's set up for a lot of movement a
certain talent of of individuals so if
you have the right team you right if you
have the right personnel 100
next question is from
the
vjb17 why do nba players have such a
hard time running offense against
zone that's a great question once you go
to a zone it makes you play straight up
you know most of the game you know
you're in attack mode if you have the
ball off a pick-and-roll or if you catch
it on the wing you're in attack mode
something about the zone that puts you
around the perimeter and it makes you
catch the ball straight up and so first
thing you're going to do besides pass
fake is try to figure out a way to pass
the ball to someone else it's not set up
for you to be in attack mode any player
that it figures out that you can still
stand attack mode you can still run your
regular offense through his own are the
best offensive teams in the game at
gabby underscore roma guys question mark
how do you break someone's ankle in
basketball it's having the ability to be
able to shift your body quick enough
stopping on a dime like this while the
defender is trying to cut your move off
and be able to bring it back or stop on
a dime and the defenders now is trying
to recover and maybe they slide or maybe
they fall or maybe they trip over their
own feet at fabio 11 is there any
traveling calls in the modern nba i
don't think so
as a fan watching the game just like you
fabio i never see a traveling call you
can call travel on almost every play and
once the nba has allowed an extra few
steps it becomes hard to even call
travel so i would say if you're a
veteran in the nba you don't get
troubles called if you're a rookie in
the nba you're gonna hear that whistle a
lot next question is from at mfort
underscore 13. should the nba move the
three-point line back and add a
four-point line absolutely not
i don't think so you know maybe you have
to ask guys who are shooting these
threes i wasn't really a three-point
shooter but i do think it's incredible
that guys are coming past how of course
shooting the ball like it's a layup but
the court is the same size the rim is
the same height like certain things is
just the same when you're trying to
match guys and say this guy is the
greatest and this guy's the greatest how
do you do that when you put a four-point
line or eventually if you put a
five-point line and then now it doesn't
make it an even playing field from the
standpoint of stacking up you know the
talent in each generation the next
question comes from at clay dave who's
the best player to never win an nba mvp
regular season he says i say dwayne wait
i don't know all the guys who have not
won
nba regular season mvp um so
clay i'm gonna go with you that guy
dwyane wade next question comes from et
hartfield annie she's never gotten a
satisfactory answer to why the harlem
globetrotters don't play in the nba so
i'd like to say this it's a lot of
basketball players who are very very
good to make it to the nba the level of
greatness you have to be the level of a
teammate you have to be is different the
harlem gold trotters and guys who play
in the playground they're more
individual players you know the nba
really focused on the team aspect and
not having five guys for individual
individually great maybe having one two
and three at max but you have to play
roles it's hard to learn how to play a
role even though you're talented in the
game of basketball next question from ed
waldy underscore 2000 how do i hit
clutch free throws it's something about
that free throw line when you up there
by yourself and everyone's watching you
it's the only time where everything
stops i always try to
visualize the moment if i miss certain
free throws in practice
i would make myself run for it and i
don't like running so i would when i get
to line i'm going to focus more and so
when i got to the game i was i was able
to be able to focus more because i know
that i didn't like you know missing free
throws you know kind of as i practice
and trying to get to that point next
question is from at dain
snz which is season underscore what nba
player has the best nickname of all time
it's a lot of guys the first one comes
to mind is paul pierce the truth i feel
like it gets no doper than that but alan
armstrong answer to be the answer that's
dope dame lillard logo lillard like
there's so many amazing nicknames but
the first one comes to mind is the truth
next question is from at esther
caroline's how do i get in
the zone i cannot tell you esther how to
get in the zone but what i can say is
once you in that zone you will never
want to leave it
next question is from at
mr2humble3 who is the hardest person in
the nba to guard well first of all it's
kevin durant he's a 6 11
maybe 7-1 depending on how kd
you know want to be perceived but it's
hard to guard a guy who has so much
talent to be able to put the ball on the
floor can score from inside the paint to
the free-throw line to the mid-range to
the three-point line back at half court
but if i had to pick another player i
would say giannis it's hard to guard
giannis because of his uh his attack
he's also 7-1
he's a footer coming down with with the
ability to be able to handle the ball he
runs fastest point guards and just as
big as the center so it's hard to guard
a guy like that who's strong and who is
aggressive in his monsters he is on a
basketball floor it's hard to guard him
as well next question comes from justin
wolfson he says i think d wade is going
to explain in his memoir how he flipped
andy v upside down on that dunk how i
think it happened is i'm coming down the
floor and i'm coming down full steam
ahead
andy is backing up right away i'm
winning because i have full force and
andy's already he's backpedaling because
he's trying to get back on defense and
so once i take off and i hit andy body
to body he doesn't have as much momentum
i have all my momentum coming this way
he only have the ability to jump
straight up this way so the force that i
was bringing coming down the court
made him not only get dunked on but made
him fall back legs flipped up
and hit the back of the uh of the thing
behind him so i think that's the way
that dunk has
been called maybe top 10 greatest dunks
um
nba of all time and it's definitely
my best dunk in my career so it's a big
moment
it was one of my favorite nba moments
every every year is one of the things
they bring back like this happened on
this date and so if they bring it back
as november 12th this happened
then you know it was some and finally
i'm gonna say kr junglas
sorry if i got that wrong what makes the
difference between a great player
and ordinary and average ones to make it
to the nba is you know 400 plus players
so it's a very small amount of
players that make it to the nba it's
millions every year that's trying to get
into the nba and what separates a player
who's who's very good and who has talent
is something as simple as the work that
you're willing to put in you know on
your craft in the at your craft is
understanding
what to work on how to work on it and
when to work on it so for me it's
something as simple as hard work a lot
of guys have talent and they think that
their talent is going to take them to
you know that level but the work that
you put in the environments you put
yourself in when you're working hard
allows you to be great in moments where
a lot of people shrink all right that's
it i hope you guys learned something
from me about my knowledge of the game
of basketball i hope you guys are as
excited as i am to pick up my new book
dwayne until next time that's all i got
you